je crois que ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure sur les sur les notamment les
fonctionnaires les mandats électifs
je crois qu'il faut un moment donné
considéré que quand on a un mandat
électif national
évidemment il faut pouvoir partir de la
fonction publique c'est pas compatible
il ya un choix à faire un certain nombre
d'entre nous d'ailleurs qu'ils étaient
dans cette situation pas moi parce que
je suis pas fonctionnaire mais d'autres
l'ont fait élan fait courageusement et
l'ont montré je pense que c'est pas
compatible
on peut pas un moment donné il faut
choisir est je pense que les gens
attendent qu'on choisisse clairement
clairement les choses je crois aussi
qu'on doit modifier notre façon de
gouverner
il faut faire plus appel au peuple il
faut probablement employée plus des
référendum
il ya d'autres pays qui font référence à
cela dans une société du numérique où
toutes les données s'échange il faut
évidemment que notre vème république qui
parfois apparaît comme extrêmement
solide mais aussi parfois un peu rigide
elle doit s'adapter à tout cela et la
manière de gouverner sera certainement
là aussi à un vrai sujet de débat dans
l'est dans les mois qui viennent